1 investigation,
several investigations even that are in progress,
which will allow uh to establish the summary of the facts about uh What happened
uh at science-po a few days ago Uh what is certain,
and what I was uh tell the members of the board of directors yesterday,
is that we attend and I deplore it since.
Uh some years now to 1 form of uh slow drift linked to 1 uh acting minority
that wants to impose 1 dominant form of thinking within this institution.
And my responsibility as Prime Minister is first
of all to keep this lucid speech,
clear in an institution that I remind you is part of the schools,
which is part of the leading executives of the state and of the public service.
And I say it very clearly,
eh,
I am committed and I committed myself at the time as Minister of Education,
I commit myself today as Prime Minister to refuse everywhere,
in any place,
any form of vague step And therefore I cannot accept that in the establishment
which forms 1 part of the future executives of the state settles 1 form
of culture of the wave step or facing 1 certain
number of drifts that everyone sees.
We let things happen.
What does the fish rotten by the head mean?
Uh,
you think of Harvard for example Because you know,
I think we have Uh The chance in France to be at this stage relatively
spared by 1 movement that we have seen effectively develop
in 1 certain number of countries,
especially Anglo-Saction.
I don't want science-po or any other school
or university to become the waterway.
Uh,
the arrival of this uh thought and finally these uh actions and initiatives
aimed at refusing that a democratic debate can be held.
I don't need to say it,
it's been said by many in recent years.
Many say,
we can no longer organize a public democratic debate at science pro.
Without having to notify the police headquarters
beforehand and bring in the security forces.
Sometimes it is even external personalities who finally give
up coming or are prevented from coming to debate.
Uh,
in this school and in this institution on Gaza You understand that part
of the French youth is moved by what is happening in Gaza.
, it's, it's,
it's subjects that are totally different,
you know.
I said it yesterday when I was in front of the board of directors on this pot,
I am well placed to know it.
Uh I frequented these benches,
it has always been the place of debate and understood the place of mobilization
on national or international topics.
It's not about questioning it,
but it can't be a place where you accept that
principles are trampled underfoot.